e est ce que vous vous regretter d'être
venu sur le plateau est ce que ça a pu
faire avancer les choses ou est ce que
vous dites ça a servi à rien on peut
tout dire ici on se dit on se dit la
vérité
franchement aujourd'hui non c'est une
très belle expérience sur le plan humain
personnel aux rencontres débats de
personnes vraiment se retrouve devant la
caméra chose que il faut pour se
retrouver il faut faire beaucoup
d'études pour vous pour son autre on se
retrouve à dix continuent de charrier
non c'est une très belle expérience
personnelle humaine sur le plan humain
rencontrer des gens mais vic
ddd dj jaune que vous connaissiez pas
parce que à un moment on s'est retrouvés
ici sur le plateau on était hier une
trentaine de gilet jaune et est ce que
vous êtes des potes ce que vous avez
changé lisier bien sûr on garde un gars
de contact ne serait pas connue vous
connaissiez pas souvent non non non il
ne dirait jamais qu'on dispose de
marseille toulouse belles choses nous
bon on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure mais sûrement j'espère je fais
partie de l'association des taxis de
l'espoir est donc le collectif des
gilets jaunes d'oeufs d'un peu partout
qui nous a mais c'est le tien c'est pour
toi suis là et c'est normal c'est moi
qui le mettait mais qu attend ben tiens
je vais le mettre jonathan hart accès
pour les foires comme jamais rien n'y a
pas compris le message
l'idée c'est que vos l'actuel porte voix
tu vois que c'est les taxis de l'espoir
marseille ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
apporte c'est une association qui
apporte du linge aux sans abri de
marseille on a les taxis de l'esport
marseille les taxis de dugard qui
apporte donc et les taxis du coeur sur
sur paris on apporte du lait chaud au
moins chaud selon la saison du café
soupe des produits d'hygiène produits de
première nécessité aux sans-abri bravo
cependant on peut l'aider sur l'état qui
dit sport qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour toi ni moi ce que je peux faire
quelque chose quoi tu as besoin
ah bah il nous faudrait un fait pousser
l'idée jusqu'à ce que tous les taxis ça
devienne nationale et ça serait
magnifique
il faudrait que toutes les personnes qui
regardent ce soir l'émission ne se
disent pas c'est super bravo la réseau
ont fait que vraiment le fasse au
quotidien que chacun lui réunions vont y
penser que chacun d'entre nous parce
qu'on est il faut être acteur bien sûr
là il faut être acteur de du bien-être
de l'autre de son prochain
voilà c'est très important avant même le
jugement parce que la première chose que
l'on dit très souvent et c'est vrai mais
bon il peut travailler où il a fait ci
fait on ne sait pas ce qui se passe dans
la vie de quelques d'une personne donc
on peut tomber
vraiment je vous le dis c'est on peut
vraiment tomber très rapidement
et pour conclure ce que tu peux faire ce
que tu peux faire ben je sais pas il
faudrait tisser un parrainage pour
l'association
on travaille ensemble d'innover en tout
cas si on va y travailler
si m6 balances ton post est partenaire
de que d'autres cordes et surtout qu'en
plus on en est maintenant à une
association en était à 20 cents
maintenant on va parler on en avait
parlé on est devenu à sion peut t'aider
voilà le faire je tiens à faire le bijou
à nicolas barrel nicolas ghilardi
stéphanie twh fait tous ces gens ils se
reconnaîtront voilà par l'émotion et
j'ai pas les normes et un travail
formidable du bénévolat c'est du pur
bénévolat et à savoir pour jouer je
finis avec ça les gens et les gilets
jaunes
ce que décrit en ce moment comme des
casseurs comme des violents on en parle
beaucoup comme ça ces gens là se sont
réunis ils font ils font des tee-shirts
je n'ai pas sur moi c'est dommage
aujourd'hui j'ai mis la même chemise que
l'élan verallia montrerait l'indien ivan
ces tee shirts dernier de suite très
vite ils valent ces t-shirts et nous ont
apporté un chèque de 400 euros qui nous
aident en ce moment pour payer une
petite part payer l'assurance du local
où on met notre loge il se passe des
choses comme ça c'est magnifique voilà
alors